[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is Caleb
Fenby and I will be your driver on this
journey today on the road I wanted to
take a look at some pretty famous games
that have happened throughout chess
history some more famous than other than
others but the common thread here is
that these are all games where the world
champion at the time ended up losing so
I thought it'd be fun to see how some of
the chesses greatest players in all of
history have slipped up throughout time
so the first game I wanted to look at is
a game of the current world champions
that is Magnus Carlsen and this is a
game that he had against Wesley so way
back in 2018 at Norway chess and this is
a game that's pretty dear to my heart
because Wesley so chose an opening that
I play myself it's an opening that
doesn't have the best reputation but if
it's enough to beat Magnus Carlsen it's
probably enough to beat just about
anybody so why don't we just take a look
see what happened the opening I'm
talking about of course happens after d4
d5 c4 c6 and then my favorite line to
play against the Slav of course C takes
d5 C takes d5 C takes d5 this is of
course the exchange Slav and now the
exchange Slav has a pretty bad
reputation for being a boring opening
prone to drawers that is pretty easy to
hold with black you know white doesn't
have much to play for but we'll see that
Wesley so actually managed to come up
with some chances here and pretty much
just outplayed the world champion Magnus
Carlsen the game continued with Bishop
f4 I think this is the best line for
white in the exchange love Knight f6 and
then Knight c3 was Wesley so choice I
kind of prefer this move
III getting this Bishop out to d3 as
quickly as possible but by no means is
that a mistake knight c6 now is
controlling the e5 square so III is
called for if you play a different move
if you play some like weird move like a3
you might even run
to some ideas of playing the
crazy-lookin 'if I've in some positions
I don't know if it works here but for
example that's something to look out for
if you play for example if knight c6
here and you play a move like Knight c3
well now II v is is definitely gonna be
on the cards so things to look out for
if you play the exchange Slav yourself
look out for these 'if I've brakes III
is usually enough to prevent it Wesley
so it shows Knight f3 instead also
controlling the e5 square now a6 is
magnus carlsen choice keeps an eye on
the b v square and helps alleviate some
pressure in case of a move like Queen b3
just makes a little bit less threatening
with this pawn already on a6 now Ric c1
is played and with a six on the board
Bishop f5 does end up being played so we
have III now and rook c8 from the
world-champion pretty natural
development this is all pretty standard
stuff now Bishop e2 for mostly so ii 6
and white castles now is really where
magnus deviates from the generally
accepted best line for black generally
the move Bishop d6 is what players with
the black pieces are playing to secure a
more or less even position the game
might continue with Bishop takes d6
Queen takes d6 and move like Knight a 4
and whites gonna look to plant this
knight on c5 as we'll see he later does
in this game and just play for some
extra space on the Queen side and try to
put some pressure on these Queen side
pawns the difference in the game is that
Magnus chose not to take these bishops
off the board
with Bishop d6 instead Magnus plays the
move Knight d7 here opting to leave
these dark squared Bishop on the board
and with this extra piece Wesley just
managed to create a few more chances for
the white pieces then if these bishops
were exchanged
Wesley continued very very naturally
though he plays Knight a of 4 aiming for
Knight c5 as I previously mentioned now
Bishop d6 of course is no longer
playable as the knight interferes with
the Queen so Bishop e7 instead is the
natural development
and here Wesley really takes his time
plays a nice move h3 just giving this
bishop some more flight squares if it
needs it and also just you know securing
the g4 square not allowing any Bishop g4
stuff it's just a nice improving move
makes left for the King even h3 pretty
good move here no need to rush things
with white Magnus went ahead and castled
and now I'd like you guys at home to try
and find Wesley says next move it's
pretty intuitive and it's more or less
the way that white should be playing in
these types of structures more or less
the way white should be playing and
there's also move I want you guys to go
ahead and try to avoid so move I think
you guys should avoid playing let's see
what you can come up with hello hello -
chess is fun also big hello to Thomas
Kirk al Hill who wanted a shout out at
the beginning in the show now that we're
deep in our position and I'm asking guys
to think I'll start saying hello to
everybody hello - Ben in the chat hello
to Ben and storm' GD all the regulars
seem to be here I'm a Doc's gamer all
the regular people so what do you guys
think
what should white be playing here and
what shouldn't white be playing here
okay Vinnie says Bishop d6 I'm assuming
he means Bishop d3 Bishop d6 would be a
little bit strange I don't really like
the move Bishop d3 White's looking to
keep this Bishop on the board because it
makes some nice pressure on the Queen
side I'm an ox gamer says Knight c5 or
Queen b3 a lot of people are saying
Knight c5 a lot of people are saying
Queen b3 and one more vote for Bishop d3
so none of you are trying to play it
like Wesley so so far I really don't
like this move Bishop d3 like simply
going to capture and you've really lost
a lot of the pressure that you had on
these these clean side pawns so this is
not going to be a favorable trade for
white so no reason to really do it the
move Knight c5 I think might be fine but
this is a move that I actually thought
you guys should maybe avoid playing for
another turn or two and the reason is
when you play Knight c5 you of course
give your opponent the option to capture
you will have to capture back with the
pawn and now you've given up a lot of
control over these dark squares in the
center so move like Bishop f6 could come
on the board and with this knight placed
on c6 black is really controlling these
central squares and it's gonna be tough
for white to gain these back you have to
play a move like 94 right away and then
even Bishop takes d4 is more or less
securing a totally even position for
black it was like Queen f6 still calm
and like I said the fight for the dark
squares is not going to be over quite so
easily so I think Knight c5 might be a
little bit premature because of this
idea or black can take and play move
like Bishop f6 just to gain control of a
lot of these dark squares another idea
you do have to look out for it's
probably not the greatest here but moves
like 'if I've are always going to be on
the cards for black so for example if
you don't play move like 90 for play
move like Queen b3
well now e5 is gonna come on the board
and this is something you have to be
very very careful of with the black Pete
or with the white pieces so instead of
all of these moves and Bobby Madden has
the right idea you want to play the move
a 3 and a 3 does a few things first and
foremost it's a pretty good waiting move
it waits for black to
mid to something so that white has more
information before committing to a move
like Knight c5 secondly it is doing
something productive by controlling the
beef for a square you're preparing to
play the movie before yourself and play
95 under slightly more favorable
circumstances so the move played in the
game is Knight a5 and this is more or
less exactly what Wesley was hoping for
with not a five note that now black has
diverted a piece away from the central
e5 square and with this change now
Wesley is more than happy to play Knight
c5 because these threats of a 5 are
going to be coming a lot more slowly
with this knight sidelined on a5 another
option for the world champion would have
been to play b5 here and now after
Knight c5 you can kind of achieve the
same stuff we were looking at earlier
with Bishop f6 but after committing to
b5 it is just going to be a little bit
worse than that first line we looked at
because this pawn on c5 is of course now
a passed pawn so white perhaps
maintaining a slight edge in this
position in particular so 95 was the
world champions choice not yet
committing to B 5 and Knight c5 the
natural follow-up for Wesley so once
again magnus diverts a piece from the
center so Wesley is more than happy to
allow this trade now note that
tactically this does work if you do take
here and take back in either rook takes
rook takes Bishop takes or Bishop takes
immediately you run into B for gaining a
piece so no worries about this pawn
hanging on c5 instead Magnus Carlsen
chose to play the move Knight c4 and
this gets into some crazy stuff after
Knight see for Wesley Soze big idea was
to play the move b4 and this is how
Wesley is securing this knight on c5
however you all at home have probably
spotted the obvious flaw with b4 that
flaw being you've left upon behind so
what is Wesley stove's idea here
well his idea is that he's really good
at calculating
and he saw that black has some serious
problems if he does end up taking on a
three so that's actually what was played
in the game perhaps a different option
for Magnus would be to play the move b5
here just securing the knight on c4 but
it does give up this a6 pawn and it's
not so easy to actually regain this pawn
black is definitely going to run into
some difficulties for example ninety
seven and Knight takes b5 might be one
way of white continuing here so instead
of that though Magnus does just capture
this pawn on a3 Alvo I should mention he
takes this night off the board first d
takes d5 and once again b5 is an option
here for black but it's that similar
type of thing where then this pawn is
just going to be a passed pawn and white
does have a nagging advantage so Knight
takes 83 comes on the board instead now
Wesley's follow-up is the nice move
Knight to d4 the point being it takes
away the night it's really only a good
retreating square in the meantime it's
also attacking this Bishop on a5 this
would be a very unfavorable trade for
black fracturing the pawns weakening d5
getting rid of the bishop so Bishop b4
is played to secure the bishop Wesley
now includes the move f3 just to drive
this Bishop back and keep control over
this efore square and now after Queen b3
Wesley is regaining his pawn comfortably
due to this night's unfortunate
placement so Knight c4 Bishop takes c4 D
takes c4 and Queen takes c4 and all of a
sudden from the notoriously Jewish
exchange love Wesley so has achieved
something what has he achieved well he's
achieved a very significant advantage in
space on this Queen side Magnus however
has gotten something in return of course
in return Magnus has achieved in the
bishops pair bishops pair is bishops
pair as some commentators would say but
in this case I really think this
advantage in space works in White's
favor compared to these bishops my
reasoning being this Bishop on g6 simply
isn't very impressive it looks at this
one diagonal but none of these squares
are particularly important for white to
use and in the meantime it's just gonna
bring a rook to d1 and with this lack in
space it's not so easy to find squares
to put these pieces on for black it's
really not easy at all in fact the move
that Magnus played here kind of
highlights how bad blacks position
actually is Queen e8 is his move of
choice and this is a very very ugly move
Magnus was trying to find some kind of
activity looking for moves like Queen a4
but for the moment it's quite clear that
blacks pieces are stepping on each
other's toes
this Queen in the way of the rook this
bishop in the way of the Queen and this
Bishop not really coordinating with the
rest of the pieces at all and so it's
the type of position where I definitely
would prefer white okay so in the game
Wesley played the very simple Bishop g3
he's just kind of sitting on the
position slowly improving his pieces
bishop g3 of course steps out of any
potential V 5 tactics when these pieces
would have been forced sorry excuse me
these these two pieces here in the game
Magnus chose to play the move e5 anyways
and I think this was a pretty committal
decision now after E 5 Magnus has really
put this pawn on a square where it's
more or less indefensible of course
there are some tactics to be aware of if
Bishop takes e5 here undoubtably Carlson
was planning Bishop takes c5 when you
would regain the pawn in the piece if
captures and captures and this is
probably what Magnus was was hoping for
but in the game Wesley does a very good
maneuver which is simply Knight b3 and
this is the way to play when you have
more space like this it's a pretty
permanent advantage in space that Wesley
so has and so he's not rushing things
he's not going directly headfirst into
tactics like Bishop takes e5 allowing
his opponent
he's keeping all of the pieces on the
board and letting the pressure slowly
build so the patience is really what is
killing Magnus here if Wesley were a
slightly more impatient impatient player
you know not playing moose like Bishop
g3 instead just going crazy with stuff
like c6 right away then Magnus would
have a lot more chances to get back into
the game instead Wesley just sits on the
position improves his pieces steps out
of any threats Magnus intends to make
and now after night b3 this is becoming
a very real threat to the e5 pawn and
Magnus plays the move Bishop d8 and
perhaps this is the move that really
cements Wesley so's advantage now after
Bishop d8 Wesley continues to improve
his pieces and plays the move Queen d5
all of a sudden this move attacks upon
on b7 this move also attacks upon on e5
and there's no way to defend both of
these pawns so this is a real like
masterclass from Leslie so really notice
he takes on c5 getting this space
advantage tactically it works out for
him because after night a3 he takes away
the Knights routing Square and then with
this space advantage he takes his time
just improves his pieces and lets Magnus
more or less dig his own grave with this
ePHI plot so once again Bishop d8
between d5 no way to solve both threats
so Queen b5 from the world champion
trying to make counter threats on this
Queen side now the time is right for
Wesley to strike so Bishop takes e5
comes on the board and who can spot the
refutation - Queen takes b4 I'll leave
this one for a tactics puzzle for you
guys at home it's a pretty fun pretty
fun line that refutes this one here what
is stopping Magnus Carlsen from
regaining his pawn on b4
what can be done
it's hello hello to Akash once again the
theme for tonight's lecture is games
where the world champions have been
defeated we're looking at the world
champions worst moments throughout
history of course it takes a lot to be a
world champion and that's why these
games are so interesting who sees the
reputation ok someone is saying TC for I
think t means rook but unfortunately
that does hang this night on b3
everybody else is saying bishops III and
the doulton Stein finds move Bishop d6
so it is actually this move Bishop d6
that is the answer yet Mohamed finds it
as well Bishop c3 isn't quite enough
here it just gains a tempo but this
Queen is very comfortable retreating
back to b5 Bishop d6 though is the
killer blow and it might not look like a
fork but in fact it is you attack this
rook on f8 if this work moves out of the
way
now the move c6 as you guys are sitting
in the chat comes onto the board and
with this tempo on the Queen Black is
just totally busted here the Queen can
move out of the way C takes b7 you get a
check but nothing more you can take care
I'll just take back and I am queening by
force so it looks pretty good just a
quick side note if V takes c6 you can
simply capture the Queen and
unfortunately for black this pawn is in
fact pinned so nice tactics from Wesley
so here to convert his positional
advantage into a material one by winning
a pawn excuse me alright so Bishop e7
from Magnus Carlsen aims to prevent
these types of Bishop d6 tactics now
once again very uncompromising play from
Wesley so he simply plays Queen d2
guarding this pawn on b4 and this is why
this position is so annoying for black
it seems like whatever black tries white
is perfectly patient totally calm just
sits on the position and
I was his opponent to make his own
mistakes it's a very magnus carlsen way
of playing actually rook FD 8 now comes
on the board in Bishop d6 from Wesley so
just putting a stopper on all of the
black pieces Bishop takes d6 is not
really what black is aiming for here as
this pawn on d6 is going to definitely
be more of a strength than a weakness
it's difficult for black to really get
at this pawn and it's quite close in
fact to becoming a queen for example
Queen b6 would hit it but now a d7 and
rook c8 ideas are already going to come
on the board the knight c5 is a very
convenient way to defend this pawn and
black is busted so okay instead of takes
Magnus goes for Bishop f6 maintaining
the bishop pair getting on a better
diagonal but now the move a4 is a bit of
a rude awakening for this Bishop on g6
this Bishop which once at least felt
like it was controlling some squares is
just totally locked out of the game now
with with nothing much to do so h6 by
Magnus creating some left and now Knight
d4 and you can really tell that Wesley
is in total control of this position up
upon none of the black pieces are
playing in this game and Wesley it's
just slowly advancing Bishop takes d4
comes on the board Queen takes d4 rook
e8 now rook e1 from Wesley getting the
pieces in the game and finally now g4
and this is Wesley's way of putting the
finishing touches on this game just
playing it totally against this bishop
and expanding on the Kings side really
impressive stuff yan wonders why bishop
d8 was played because the bit tactic we
wish Bishop takes e5 still existed and
well the the reasoning is what else do
you play I'll jump back to that position
at the end if if I remember hopefully
but let's keep going for the moment f6
gives this bishop some squares but now
with all of the black pieces out of the
game Wesley is perfectly fine pushing
even more pawns in front of his king f4
Queen c6 and now
five Bishop f7 and this game is pretty
much dead who can find the next moves
for Wesley so they are pretty consistent
with his place so far but I'll let you
go ahead at home try and find the real
finishing touches that Wesley put on
this game I'm looking for a pretty short
term plan not just one move not just two
moves but kind of a plan
it doesn't take Wesley long to enact it
but it is more of a plan than a then the
specific series of moves here so see
what you guys can come up with
so yes Oh garsh Denish Boros as of May
1st it is going to be our new grand
master in residence however dorsa is
actually just a chess club employee as
well so stay tuned she'll be teaching a
class or tooth care out the week and
maybe even doing some streams ok
Mohammed says 'if I've and Vinnie
Beneatha says h4 Marcin says 'if I've
Vinnie vanitas switches his guests to e5
keV to e5 e6 so you guys haven't quite
found Wesley's idea here everybody
thinks it's the movie v e5 is really
letting black off the hook a little bit
this throws away a significant portion
of your advantage I think F takes e5
comes on the board and if you take well
now black will take for example Queen
takes rook e8 Queen g3 and all of a
sudden the black pieces have gotten
themselves into the game you have to be
very careful here very careful so efore
kind of throws away the bind that Wesley
has on this position okay Ben even Etha
has the right idea now as does Yan and
Metis as well as chess is fun h4 and g5
is how Wesley still wanted to continue
the game and this is a perfect example
of how to convert a position where you
have a spatial advantage in this case of
course Wesley is also up upon which
definitely does his position some good
but when you have an advantage in space
the thing that tends to happen is you
cut the board in half with this central
space for example this bishop prevents
these pieces from easily accessing the
Kings side of the board
so because the black pieces are sort of
split apart like this you want to aim to
create threats on both sides of the
board so with the pieces locked on the
Queen side for black Wesley is now
looking to make threats around the black
King using this extra space and because
he has the extra space it's a lot easier
to get the white pieces into this side
of the board than it is or black so when
you have a spatial advantage like this
this is really a great way to make use
of it you try and create threats on both
sides of the board or at least the side
that is difficult for your opponent to
reach so here Wesley Soze move h4 rook
e8 was Magnus choice desperately trying
to find counter play over here and it
turns out the best move for Wesley it
was simply just to play g5 instead
though he played a preparatory move rook
C to Magnus now continues with a five
and now Wesley does continue with g5 and
this is also just gonna be more or less
totally winning
now g5 does in fact make its threat of
g6 of course it'd be suicidal to take
and open the H file this is just gonna
be devastating instead Bishop h5 from
Magnus tries to hold on
and now the simple move g6 Scheck was
Wesley so choice turns out G takes f6
was was probably good enough just to
home winning all these Kings side pawns
but g6 was what Wesley chose to play and
now King h8 and Wesley chose this move
b5 a nice little sacrifice here to keep
this Rick out of the game
and in fact activate Wesley's own pieces
so you see he made threats on the Kings
side now this King is going to be
permanently weak on the h8 square and
now Wesley so is going for threats on
the Queen side this idea of threats on
both sides of the board now perhaps for
Magnus Queen d7 would have held on with
a bit more tenacity instead though Queen
c6 was his choice now rook b6 comes with
tempo and after Queen c8 and the move
Queen d5 is deadly this is just deadly
for Magnus a4 was tried but after rook
takes b7 now there's a threat of rook
takes g7 so Rick g8 comes on the board
but after c6 Magnus Carlsen had seen
enough and resigned this position so
this is a real favorite game of mine of
Wesley sose showing that the exchange
Slav can have some winning chances now
there was a question earlier on about a
bishop d8 move that Magnus chose to play
so why don't we jump back to that
position so here after Knight b3 I was
talking about how there's pressure on
this e5 pawn lasting pressure
and there's this tactic where white
captures then Bishop takes c5 wins back
the piece and the pawn so why after
Knight B 3 did Magnus play bishop d8
well it's simply a matter of what else
do you play you can play a move like
like age six and it's true
that's a bishop takes e5 is still not
going to be the best move for white due
to this but white is really in no hurry
simply move like H like efore you start
bringing your works to the center and
this is going to be a permanent problem
for you here so it was more of a
question of you know what else do you
play with black that's why I think
Bishop d8 was in fact played not on
twitch yeah Jo so the last class of the
evening analyze your games will take
place on twitch but the road to 2000 is
traditionally a youtube class okay so
with that in mind this is a really model
game from Wesley so as I said showing
how to play with more space but showing
that the exchange Slav does in fact have
some tricky bits to it and that you need
to avoid and I think this is one of the
last games Magnus Carlsen lost in
standard chests that guy just doesn't
lose anymore
I guess he just figured it out it
doesn't lose any more so a good game
from Wesley so to take out the current
world champion why don't we move on to a
slightly more famous game where a former
world champion was defeated this is a
game between Garry Kasparov and the
controversial computer deep blue and
this is a game that deep blue ended up
winning and it's a pretty fun one so I
thought we'd take a look at it so II for
c5 was played c3 going for the elephant
the c3 sicilians and these are known for
being a little bit less less ambitious
for a white less tactical less
challenging just going for simple D for
stuff now who in the chat knows why the
c3 Sicilians are less challenging
what is the move for black that really
highlights why is c3 is not the most
testing move who knows I'll give you
just a second
- - think about it just a second okay
hopefully everybody at home knows it is
this move d5 by playing c3 you take away
your option to play Knight c3 taking
away your option to challenge the d5
square
so after d5e takes d5 Queen takes d5 the
Queen is simply going to be an active
piece for black and he should have no
trouble completing his development and
surviving the opening when has this been
played this is the 1996 match between
Garry Kasparov and deep blue I believe
let me double check yet 1996
okay now d4 comes on the board for white
and black simply continues development
with the move Knight f6 now Knight f3
and Bishop g4 aims to pin the night it
should be to simply unpinned and now e6
like I said this opening not the most
challenging from white actually black
just finishes development quite
naturally so e6 h3 was his choice this
Bishop drops back to h5 and now castles
knight c6 from Gary challenging the
center a bit more it should be three
controlling the center a bit more now we
have C takes d4 and C takes D for
accepting an isolated queen pawn
position now if you guys are familiar
with iqp type of positions kind of the
nature of them is that in the long run
white is going to have some spatial
advantage in the center giving him an
advantage in activity meanwhile black is
going to have a more or less permanent
weakness on the d4 square this pawn with
no other pawns to back it up can become
a bit weak so we'll see how the computer
and Gary both chose to approach this
position so Bishop b4
was Gary's choice in the game now a3 by
deep blue bishop back to a 5 and this is
actually not the most common way of
playing with black these days these days
Bishop e7 is more generally Black's most
common option and the point is you just
don't give white this 8 to remove with
tempo after Knight c3 you'll bring this
Queen back to d6 and it looks a little
bit awkward for the black pieces but you
do avoid giving a through of tempo that
being said though Bishop before
Gary's choice in the game a3 Bishop a5
and now Knight c3 by deep blue hits this
Queen in the center so the Queen
retreats back to d6 95 in his deep blues
choice and after Queen d5 who's to say
if deep blue was intending to repeat
maybe deep blue had some other ideas
playing a move like before for example
could be considered moves like g4 as
well also on the cards but Gary didn't
give it the chance to repeat instead
choosing Queen East 7 with the idea that
you are just keeping things solid and
controlling a5 a bit more hinting at
maybe an e5 break later in the game also
clearing off this d file for a rook to
come but ok in the game 95 was deep
blues choice allowing Bishop take c2
Queen take c2 and black simply casas now
we're okay c1 comes on the board
Rick AC 8 the players bring the rooks
into the game and Bishop g5 is deep
blues choice so deep blue really hasn't
done too much to really pressure
Gary's position in this game it's just
hoping to use this deep on as a hook for
a knight on e5 and with this knight on
e5 just a little bit more comfortable
with the white pieces then with the
black pieces so there is some tactical
issues here for white for example if a
six you do I think have to include this
move Knight takes c6 to a leave pressure
on d4 and then we could see kind of the
pieces explode off the board
for example Queen takes f6 would allow a
knight a7 move and so it's just a little
bit tough for Gary to immediately
clarify things which is probably you
want probably what you know the black
player desires in these positions you
want more clarity to get to the type of
endgame where you know you're just going
to be totally fine with this weakness on
d4 fortunately it's not so easy to get
there after the move a 6
in the game Gary goes for this move
Bishop b6 instead putting more pressure
on d4 the only issue with this is that
now after the move Bishop takes f6 it's
not so easy to play Queen takes f6
you're gonna get hit with 97 when you're
losing in fact an entire exchange so not
ideal so after Bishop takes f6 the move
G takes f6 has to come on the board as
it does and now the move Knight c4 is
deep blues choice so what's preventing
net takes d4 I hear you asking at home
well we can simply take this piece and
after takes back we have Queen g4 check
already highlighting the weakness in
blacks position
so instead Brooke f2 d8 is Garry
Kasparov's choice and already deep blue
has a little bit of an advantage Gary
just played Oh slightly and accurately
with the pieces here allowing this
weakness to be forged on the Kings side
if I can use such a word
and with this weakness around the King
white should be able to kind of maneuver
the pieces to be just ever so slightly
better in fact Knight takes b6 was
played in the game a takes b6 and then
my present-day computer says that after
queen g4 King h8 and rook d1 move like
f5 could come and to Queen f4 and white
just has a little bit of pressure here
threats of d5 later to come threats of
g4 even could be on the cards to break
down this King side structure it moves
like C rook c3 and over to somewhere on
the Kings side can also be on White's
mind instead in the game deep blue
actually played slightly inaccurately
here not choosing to include this move
Queen g4 check and it turned out that
this really threw away much of his
advantage so Rick FD 1 comes instead now
the move f5 is very accurate by Kasparov
guarding this g4 squared not giving like
the chance to get this Queen on the
slightly more active f4 square so white
settles for e3 instead of that
or and that's just the slight difference
in this game that really allowed Gary to
equalize here now Queen f6 comes on the
board it's very sensible for Gary to try
and pressure in this d4 pawn and then
deep blue kind of relents and goes for
d5 after d5 things get a lot more simple
for both sides
he takes d5 b3 and what do we have now
well Gary Kasparov is up upon but of
course he is playing with quite a large
number of weaknesses so it's actually
totally impossible for black to hold
together everything here so Gary simply
plays the move King h8 allowing white to
regain the pawn on d6 and go for some
active play so black plays the move for
a g8 and this is a very sensible move
taking advantage of the open G file and
then white plays the move Queen c5 now
if you're Gary Kasparov what move do you
think you should play here see if you
can play it better than Gary because
Gary's next to move more or less lost
the game for them so I'm interested if
the chat can figure out the way to to
equalize here or to secure an equal
position for Gary what can be done
what can be done as I watched the chat
[Music]
I know I've gone through the game pretty
quickly up to this point but the real
highlight of this game is this tactical
finish so that's why we've gone straight
to the goods
so it looks like you guys have some
pretty good ideas here of course black
is always going to have the worst
structure in this position what does
black have in exchange for it well he's
got pressure on the kingside so it's
very logical that blacks counterplay to
get eek to achieve equality is to go for
this pressure on the Kings side rather
than spend all of his time defending
things on the Queen side in the center
you know this type of active counter
play is really what blacks should be
aiming for here and the fact is Gary
just played a little bit too slowly now
this move 95 isn't my favorite because I
think white could in fact just favorably
take this pawn on d5 guarding against
whatever threats you just made but some
other choices that you guys were saying
are a little bit better Queen B 2 also
isn't really my favorite move in history
it's just kind of vacating the Kings
side a little bit too much the moves I
do like that I'm seeing in the chat are
these moves f4 and this move Queen g5
these are the 2 moves that I really
think secure equality for Gary and the
reason they do is really the same for
both moves let's start with Queen g5
well now you've got a very serious
problem on your g2 square the only way
to solve this is to play the move g3 if
you dare play Queen takes in d5 well
you've hung a rook on c1 so g3 only way
to deal with this and then there's the
natural follow-up f4 and this is going
to be good enough for Gary to end up
securing at least a draw in this game
the only way I think is sensible to play
it for white is with g4 you can throw in
moves like 96 if you like forcing the
Queen to come back and follow a g4 but
we'll just start with g4 now for example
Queen h4 makes a threat Queen c3 check
is trying to defend and after move like
Knight d4 well we can simply take and
take and now Gary's going to be able to
break through with a move like Age 5
and this is just going to be a dead draw
in fact
the play could continue with something
like Queen takes f4h takes G for Queen
at five G takes h3 check King age to
rook G to check King h1 and after move
like d4 it's pretty clear that the only
player having any fun in this position
is really going to be Gary with all of
this pressure around the White King just
for example I move like Rick see it
check it's gonna be met with York g8 and
after move like rook c7 Brooke g7 and
you can imagine that this is how a game
could have ended so Gary really should
have gone for this active active play on
the Kings side
now if f4 first it's more or less the
same I think if Queen takes d5
well now f3 is going for similar types
of counter play for example g4 and a
move like Queen h6 is already making
these types of threats making these
types of threats okay instead though
Gary chose D for responding to a threat
in the center so now I'm going to flip
flip it over to the chat once again Gary
played the slightly inaccurate d4 how do
you pounce with white how do you take
advantage of this slight misstep from
Gary Kasparov a dead draw was probably
probably the wrong word
the point of that final position the
reason it's it's drawn is neither player
can really risk too much or else their
own king is going to get eviscerated so
that's why you end up with these weird
types of repetitions with fake rook c8
rook c7 or Chi 8 or g7 because neither
player can really bring the pieces away
from their own King without getting
killed
is your in it seems to have the correct
answer it is in fact this move Knight d6
you bring this Knight to a phenomenal
square on d6 and you are really just
attacking all sides of the board here
and now in the game Gary does finally go
for this f4 move but it's simply too
little too late now after Knight takes
b7 you're not in time with things like
f3 simply g3 will come on the board and
there's no good solution to this
placement of this night instead Gary
tries Knight e5 first which is in fact a
better tribe but now the active accurate
follow-up from deep blue is the move
Queen d5 and the point here is you guard
g2 and you attack f7 and these are
really the two critical squares here so
f3 comes on the board very naturally
from Gary Kasparov now in g3 is the
defense for deep blue now 93 is what
Gary Kasparov tried but the move rook c7
and all of a sudden White has built some
sort of shelter around his own King and
the shelter around blacks King seems to
be crumbling and this is where deep blue
ended up killing its opponent rook e8
was Gary Kasparov stripe and who on this
earth can see the win now for deep blue
who can see the way to end Garry
Kasparov
who sees the win who sees the win okay
not gonna wait the entire delay of
course the win here is not to play move
leg rope takes f7 then after the move
Ricky one check King age to the knight
takes F to all of a sudden you've got
some very serious problems around your
own King here Queen takes up three would
have to come on the board but after it
takes and takes and is actually black
who is kind of playing for the win here
example it takes F two rookie to got to
play King G one and all of a sudden d2
and you are sacrificing a rook and
getting into some type of drawn end game
so very serious problems around the
white king so you cannot play move like
ER takes f7 because you're gonna get
ignored and checkmate is going to be
threatened so instead of rook takes f7
the best move of course is Knight to d6
the point Bing rookie won check as
played in the game King age to Knight
takes f2 and what's the idea for Garry
Kasparov
well Knight takes f7 is a check now of
course if Queen takes f7 we are not
recapturing this piece hanging matin one
instead where you're going for this move
Queen d8 with check and this is the
killer blow can't play King g7 as this
falls with check as does this for
example Rick takes f7 is check and then
I suppose we can just solve this this
problem on h1 in in this manner Queen
takes f3 and white is up a Queen's so
you can't play King g7 sorry I was
second-guessing myself for for a second
and you can't play the move Queen g8
because Queen takes e5 is going to be a
checkmate so Knight takes f7 is the
killer blow from deep blue now King g7
was Garry Kasparov's choice but this is
a bit hopeless Knight g5 is check King
age six rook takes h7 is check and
checkmate will follow shortly garry
kasparov simply resigned but if the move
King g6 now
when g8 comes on the board King f5 and
Knight takes f3 and this King is simply
getting murdered and white is safe after
this f3 pawn falls off the board so that
is how deep blue managed to take out
Garry Kasparov in this game from the
1996 match it looks simple enough here
but doing two blacks opening play
leaving himself with all of these
weaknesses to look after he forced
himself or backed himself into a little
bit of a corner where he had to find
some very accurate play on the Kings
side to get counter play to negate
White's threats to all of these Queen
side pawns and Gary simply didn't find
it okay I have one more game for you
guys to go over here tonight and it is a
game between Veselin Topalov
and visi not and this is a game actually
from their World Championship match way
back I believe in 2010 8 2010 from the
2010 World Championship match and this
is a match that's actually pretty dear
to me it's the first World Championship
that I followed live I had a great time
watching this one back when I was a
little kid oh and it was a lot of fun to
see these two players battle it out and
this is a game that of course went
vessel ins way because we're looking at
losses by the world champions but it is
a very very fun game from both players
nonetheless so let's just take a look
once again it's gonna be a d4 game we
have Knight f6 c4 I mean g6 from the XI
Anand after Knight c3 d5 and vichy
pulled out the green felt in this world
championship a lot of fun so C takes d5
was played in the game now Knight takes
d5 you for this is mainline stuff we
have Knight takes c3 B takes c3 Bishop
g7 Bishop c4 c5 is natural from black to
challenge these central pawns 92 from
white supports them know that white goes
to e 2 rather than f3
because after f3 you're just a little
bit more
prone to getting pinned with Bishop g4
later on in the game so 92 instead now
we have knight c6 Bishop e3 castles
castles and 9 a 5 from black this is a
pretty common maneuver in the green felt
and it's a common line against this
Bishop c4 stuff just hitting the bishop
the bishop drops back to d3 and now
black plays this move b6 just to support
his c5 pawn a little bit more and
perhaps prepare to bring this Bishop out
to be 7 where it can challenge these
central pawns White's next move is Queen
d2 and this is really a decision point
for Vichy and on now so far white has
pretty much just played the most natural
moves got the pieces out supported the
center brings the Queen up prepares to
bring her ex to the center and prepares
to challenge this Bishop here on h6 and
in the game Vichy went for a highly
committal move that goes in for a line
that Minot might not actually be the
most comfortable for black you could
just play very simply with a move like
Bishop e7 and kind of keeping the
tension here why it's likely going to
continue with Bishop h6 after something
like C takes d4 this should take g7 in
takes g7 and C takes d4 you just have
this little type of game where white
still maintains these central pawns and
black tries to get on the C file and
find counter play over here this is one
option for black and instead vichy
played the slightly more testing line
with E 5 and with E 5 black is shutting
down all of the dark squares for white
now no matter what happens
black is going to gain some dark squares
in this Center for example if you place
some nothing move like f3 well already
in fact you're losing your d4 pawn it
gets quite difficult quite quickly one
option for white is to play a move like
d5 but now this d4 square is totally
under black's control and they move like
f5 is going to be slightly awkward for
white to deal with with pressure on this
e4 pawn already
in the game Veselin Topalov goes for the
most active try for white which is in
fact simply to sacrifice in this d4 pawn
he plays the move Bishop h6 and I really
like this type of play from vessel in
here and this is the type of
uncompromising play that it really takes
to beat a a sitting world champion you
can't really win chess games without
sacrificing well not sacrificing without
risking something without taking some
amount of risk and Wesley Soze game that
was the risk incurred by allowing Magnus
to kind of take this a3 pawn and get the
bishops pear and the deep blue game this
was kind of the risk incurred by deep
blue by allowing Gary all this active
play on the Kings side and in this game
the risk incurred by Veselin Topalov is
allowing the world champion to take on
d4 so each game we see a player beat the
world champion they do in fact have to
risk something so no victory without
risk since he takes d4 is played Bishop
takes g7 now King takes g7 C takes d4
and he takes d4 and black is securely up
a pawn rook a c1 is Veselin Topalov
choice taking advantage of this hat
that's totally open file Queen d6 from
Vichy and then who thinks they can find
the plan for white what is White's plan
in this position
you've just sacrificed upon you need
active play where are you going to find
it where can you find the active play
you need something special for white
here otherwise your opponent up a clean
pawn
I'm a dogs gamer has the plan that was
played on the game of course f4 and f5
is the way to go here with white you
want to try and break down this kingside
try and make use of these weak dark
squares by attacking this king
so f4 f5 definitely the way to go
for white what you don't want to do is
play move like rook FD 1 because this is
this is chess for babies this is oh my
god I'm so scared I gave up a pawn
please don't hurt me a Vishy Anand
please just let me take my pawn back I
promise I won't try to win just give me
a pawn just I want my pawn back I'm so
scared so you can't beat world champions
like that of course remove like rook da
could be played it maybe after Knight g3
oh well sorry and maybe you have to move
like Bishop e5 you are in fact going to
regain a pawn on d4 but it's it's not
really what you want out of life it's
just not what you want so f4 is the way
to go f4 challenging black on the Kings
side this she went with f6 and the
reasoning behind f6 is you want to meet
the move f5 first with Queen e5 in this
case and after Knight f4 making serious
threats to this pawn with the move g5
visi adopts this type of dark square
defense by placing these pawns onto
these squares now in the game Topalov
goes for Knight h5 check this King steps
back to g8 and now once again you are
faced with the question of how to break
down this structure so your opponent has
given you what's called a hook with the
g5 pawn a hook and chest I've taught a
lecture on before it's something you can
latch on to to try and open up files so
in this case you of course want to latch
on to the g5 hook by playing aged floor
this is how you kind of grab onto the
hook you challenge it with another pawn
now the move g4 is simply way too much
Queen h6 is already checkmating rook at
4 or takes you for you can't play like
this so h6 is the corner vichy nod finds
himself backed into now
Topol have simply captures on g5 you
know
age takes g5 there is this open age file
for white to use in the game Topa live
goes for rock f3
perhaps preparing to come over to h3 and
black plays king f7 now who can find the
winning move for Topalov how did topple
of win this game how to continue how to
win how to bust open the black king side
tt0 knows this game it is a pretty
famous one most world championship games
are
who has the answers who knows
so far nobody odd Rahul has the answer
of course the way to break through here
is with the killer the absolute killer
move Knight takes f6 this is how you get
at this black King and it's how you end
up winning the game if your name is
Veselin Topalov King takes f6 was a
nonce choice if you do take this back
with the Queen
well now the move rook h3 is going to
come on the board and this King is kind
of getting attacked from both sides and
that is really the difficulty faced here
by a not let's stick with the game
though King takes f6 still drag h3 it
comes on the board it's a very similar
problem now in rook g8 by Vishy Anand
but this simply means check King f7
check of course if you block this you're
going to face capture win after King
takes there's Queen takes g5 with some
checkmates and after Queen takes there's
rook c7 picking up the Queen just to
show you King takes that means Queen
takes d5 check King f8 Queen da check
Queen e8 Queen f6 check Queen f7 Queen
okay it's getting a bit silly let me
stop and think for a moment okay Queenie
six check Queen e7 and just to move like
Queen f4 is going to be enough and now
these pawns are going to come up the
board this rook is going to come into c7
and you are going to get killed so
that's why Rick g7 was not played
instead king e e8 but now after the move
rook C to C 7 this game is going to be
dead King d8 played in the game Bishop
b5 the final blow from Veselin Topalov
and after Queen takes e4 the move for a
take ca was enough for this XI to resign
the game of course now if King takes
Queen c1 is check with checkmates or you
know you can throw a knight in the way
and don't I'll take it and if Rick takes
the movie
d7 check is picking up this Queen quite
simply and that is how Veselin Topalov
managed the feat Vishy Anand in this
game in the World Championship match of
course this she went on to win this
match anyhow coming back with fire for
Veselin Topalov so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this lecture tonight on ways
world champions have lost chess games in
the past and hopefully you picked up a
few tricks learned a little something
from it as well if you're watching live
be sure to stay tuned for the endgame
class coming up right after this still
here on this youtube channel if you're
watching the video thank you very much
for joining me my name is Caleb Denby
and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]